eine wichtige meldung aus der korona
politik weg mit dem chor ohne regeln
eigentlich nix da in brandenburg
zumindest darstellt die grüne
gesundheitsministerin die korona ampeln
wieder auf alarm roth alle bisherigen
einschränkungen sollen dort bleiben und
einiges soll sogar noch verschärft
werden darüber müssen wir sprechen hier
im studio mit bildpolitik chef jan
schäfer grüße dich an alex mit freedom
day das ist erledigt die zeiten laufen
wieder genau andersrum in welchen
bundesländern der freedom day ausfällt
das versuchen wir gerade noch zu
recherchieren das ist noch nicht ganz
klar es gibt einige deutliche hinweise
gerade was süddeutschland angeht aber
auch was den westen angeht und wir
wissen es ganz konkret in der tat aus
brandenburg unser kollege michael
sauerbier der dort die meldung auch ans
tageslicht gebracht hat dass die meisten
maßnahmen dort auf jeden fall über den
20 märz also über den kommenden sonntag
hinaus verlängert werden sollen das
heißt ganz klar wie du es auch gerade
schon gesagt hast der freedom day denen
die ampel regierung ausgerufen hat ende
vergangener woche der ist damit
zumindest in brandenburg möglicherweise
auch in berlin und in weiteren
bundesländern erst mal vom tisch so es
ist ja wohl in der korona krise dass man
immer wieder gelernt hat man kann sich
da nicht so richtig auf irgendwelche
aussagen verlassen deswegen muss ich
sagen an den frieden data war schon
immer dass mir auf der überhaupt kommt
und wenn man sich genauer anschaut dann
sieht man ja auch dass man überhaupt
nicht wirklich etwas konkretes
festgelegt hat zumindest sagte auch der
gesundheitsminister schwellenwert
angemerkt bringen uns gar nichts wir
orientieren uns jetzt an sogenannten hot
spots und schauen uns da die
krankenhäuser an dass er bleibt aber
ziemlich vage was ist deine einschätzung
dazu woran orientiert man sich und wie
viele bundesländer kommen deiner meinung
nach überhaupt dann in den genuss
vorerst eines freedom day ist es gibt
eine neue gemenge lage die hat die ampel
auf den weg gebracht und zwar gab es ja
immer wieder in den vergangenen monaten
und jahren muss man ja fast sagen
entscheidungen von einzelnen
landesregierungen
beispielsweise masken pflicht oder geht
zweig 3 im handel was immer wieder von
den gerichten vor ort auch gekippt wurde
und da hat die ampel bundesregierung
gesagt das wollen wir künftig nicht mehr
so machen wir möchten dass das
infektionsschutzgesetz in seiner
jetzigen form ausläuft und geben mehr
für antworten an die einzelnen
bundesländer und vor allem dort auch an
die landtage also dass künftig nicht
mehr eine landesregierung einfach sagen
kann 'die und die maßnahme die muss
jetzt neu eingeführt werden und die muss
gelten sondern dass die landtage das
beschließen müssen so und auf der
anderen seite haben wir karl lauterbach
vergangenen freitag ja auch gehört
kommen würde gern einmal rein
das macht mir große sorge die lage ist
objektiv viel schlechter als die
stimmung die stimmung in der bevölkerung
auch mit teueren der politischen
landschaft ist so dass wir auch so
dietmann mich schon bewältigt hätten ja
und dann kommt er als stimmungskiller
und hat jetzt ist auch geschafft
offenbar die stimmung wieder schlechter
zu machen genau und er sagt nach diesen
sätzen die wir gerade gesehen haben
anschließend noch dass er davon ausgeht
dass viele länder sehr schnell die
maßnahmen weiter laufen lassen bzw
entscheidungen treffen dass maßnahmen
weiter noch mehr hat eigentlich am
vergangenen freitag jetzt schon muss man
sagen diesen freedom day für zahlreiche
bundesländer abgepfiffen und weil die
frage auch gerade kam ja um welche
bundesländer handle es sich denn wir
sehen wenn man einmal auf die
infektionszahlen schaut auf die
sogenannte incidents dann beispielsweise
auch mecklenburg vorpommern mit einer
sehr hohen inzidenz aktuell brandenburg
auch aber wir wissen auch zb dass markus
söder ja mit dem was die ampel da
beschlossen hat die ganze zeit schon hat
es wird sich zeigen ob das eigentlich
nur polit taktische argumentation sind
die erde immer bringt und sagt das kann
nicht sein dass die ampel so regiert
oder ob er es wirklich auch in seinem
bundesland umsetzt dass man abzuwarten
wir sind auf jeden fall bei bild bei
bild live dabei und werden unsere
leserinnen und zuschauer die ganze zeit
darüber unterrichten in welchen
bundesländern wird denn eigentlich der
freedom day möglich am wochenende und wo
schelte aus denn da muss man wirklich
sagen jan ist es nicht so ganz einfach
den überblick zu behalten ich finde
gerade jetzt in dieser gemengelage ist
es irgendwie schwierig zu sagen was gilt
überhaupt für meinen bundesland wie muss
ich mich dort verhalten und ich hatte so
darauf gesetzt ist zumindest die masken
pflicht jetzt in den schulen kippt aber
ich glaube nicht mal da kann man sich so
tausendprozentig sicher sein das kann
man nicht in der tat und was wir aus
brandenburg sehen das könnte natürlich
eine vorlage auch für andere länder sein
da geht die masken pflicht bei es weise
weiter und zwar nicht nur bei in bussen
und bahnen sondern dann auch zb beim
friseur oder auch in hotels und
gaststätten auch in den tests und
gaststätten soll die 3g regelung weiter
gelten wenn man eine disco möchte
beispielsweise sogar die 2g regelung
also da gibt es richtig scharfe
maßnahmen die wir aus zeiten kennen
eigentlich die wir gehofft hatten lange
hinter uns gelassen zu haben danke bild
politik chef jan schäfer der freedom day
der jetzt zumindest in den ersten
bundesländern ganz offenbar abgepfiffen
es ausfällt danke dir ja